thank you so much uh Tim and Matt and
everybody it's such an honor to be here
I've been a great fan of Hillsdale for a
while and um so to be here today is such
a thrill
I guess um to start I'll just say that
the 2020 election was a great
disappointment to conservatives and
Patriots
um but it was also a rare opportunity I
see it as a sort of a wormhole into
another dimension it allowed us
for once to see how our democracy now
works it's not
you know where where people get together
on Election Day and they elect the
leaders who
um you are going to enact policies that
are good for the country and that they
broadly agree with
um know what we have is a situation or
certainly we had in 2020 where
um our abetters decided that we were
going to get the leaders that they
wanted
and
um
they did that by showing their
relationship with big Tech the
mainstream media the intelligence
Services most especially the FBI and
um so they had determined that Donald
Trump was an existential threat that in
the words of the liberal atheist public
intellectual Sam Harris
uh it was Donald Trump was like a
meteorite that was hurtling towards
Earth and you would do anything to save
the planet from such a threat
and of course that's what they did and
even some people who regard themselves
as Patriots and good moral people did
the wrong thing to ensure that Donald
Trump did not get elected and that's
because they feel that they are morally
and intellectually superior to the
American people and that they have to
protect the American people from
themselves and from their poor choices
like voting for Donald Trump or you know
driving a real car or
eating meat or not getting a covert jab
every couple of minutes
so
what we saw
um
from them in 2020
was their decision that Joe Biden would
become the president
and I I note today that Joe Biden has
yet again Fallen up the stairs of Air
Force 2 in Poland
and
um you know not to disrespect the
commander-in-chief
but
I will note that he does have certain
cognitive and ethical problems but that
these were manifestly evident before the
2020 election I would argue many decades
before
and
um but that did not matter you know he
was not Donald Trump that was all that
mattered
um so we can thank Sam Harris for being
honest and to sort of uh blurt out what
his ilk had been blurring for the
previous two years
and
um
I think
my personal
um understanding and view Through the
Wormhole came about because of the
hunter Biden laptop and
um it was about a month before the
election I was it was late on a Friday
night and um
I got a text message from Bob Costello
who was Rudy giuliani's
um
uh lawyer and Rudy Giuliani of course
was Donald Trump's lawyer and he just
sent me uh three photographs
and he said you know this is legitimate
we should talk about this in the morning
and the photographs were from Hunter
Biden's laptop they were not
pornographic I'm glad to say I probably
wouldn't have called him back but
um which was unusual because most of the
photographs on that laptop are
pornographic but
oh not most but a lot of them
um but one of them were a very arresting
photograph was the middle-aged son of
Joe Biden candidate for president asleep
with a crack pipe in his mouth
and so I thought well this is could be a
good story so
I had long conversations the next day
with um Bob Costello and Rudy Giuliani
now both of them had worked for the
southern district of New York uh you
know of course really Giuliani
um was the mayor who saved New York and
Bob Costello had been very close to him
as the I think he was um associate head
of the Criminal Division of the southern
district of New York or The Sovereign
District of New York as it used to be
called very powerful position
and a mind like a steel trap and he and
or he actually first had had a copy of
Hunter Biden's laptop on a hard drive
since the end of August when the um
John Paul Mac Isaac who was the owner of
a small computer repair store in
Delaware just in the local shopping
center next to where Joe Biden and his
son Hunter both lived and John Paul Mac
Isaac
had received this laptop from Hunter
Biden in April of 2019 Hunter had
brought it off it was waterlogged it was
difficult to access and so John Paul Mac
Isaac had to upload very slowly this
broken laptop onto his Mainframe
computer in the store and while he was
doing that he did notice that there was
a lot of porn but he also noticed you
know documents and and so on words like
barisma came up a lot and not that he
was reading at that stage he was just
doing his job and but hunter Biden never
came back to pick up his laptop he never
paid his 85 bill
and so after 90 days the work order that
Hunter Biden signed that rainy night in
April 2019
ensured that John Paul Mac Isaac was now
the legal owner of the laptop
and it just sat on a Shelf
for quite a while but John Paul Mac
Isaac happened to be a republican voter
and he happened to be a big fan of
Donald Trump which is not a crime
um and he had noticed watching uh his
television that Donald Trump was
enmeshed in this Ukraine Scandal which
would become the impeachment that Nancy
Pelosi was pushing
and he noticed a word barisma which he
recognized from the laptop so he went
back and he opened the laptop and he
looked it up and he was a very he is a
very smart guy and very analytical very
good at putting two and two together and
he was horrified by what he saw on the
laptop uh not just the pawn or the drug
use but really the evidence that he
thought was uh somehow related to our
national security
and so he decided that he had to do
something with it and so he contacted
the FBI
and uh you know he's a law-abiding man
and he wasn't going to the media he went
to the authorities and he tried to
impress upon the FBI the National
Security implications of what was on the
laptop because what he'd seen was vast
sums of money that were being paid by
countries like China Russia Ukraine
Kazakhstan Romania
um not exactly you know upright citizen
countries a lot of very corrupt
countries we're paying money to the
Biden family not just tun to Biden but
his Uncle Jim Biden who's Joe Biden's
younger brother
um and uh that was throughout Joe
Biden's vice presidency and there's also
evidence on the laptop that Joe Biden
had met with many of these at least a
dozen we've now counted of uh of Hunter
Biden and Jim Biden's overseas business
partners which is uh went flew in the
face of his
repeated denials during the election
campaign that he knew anything about his
son Hunters overseas business dealings
he would get very angry and bark at
journalists who dared to bring up the
topic so many of them just didn't
and um so
this phone call from from Rudy Giuliani
and and Bob Costello with these phone
calls I had the next day
um obviously had to go up the line and
so I would say the unsung hero in all of
this and the man that I dedicated the
book to is Carl Allen who was my editor
at the New York Post the top editor at
the New York Post at the time
um he's an Australian from a country
town in Australia called dubbo and uh he
knows a story and he's very courageous
and so it took a lot of Courage for them
for the newspaper for all the editors to
go ahead and publish a story that was
really detrimental to one of the two
candidates for president just three
weeks before the 2020 election and of
course there was a flurry of active
activity my very talented colleagues
like Emma Joe Morris uh nailed all the
details of the laptop talk to John Paul
Mac Isaac got hold of the subpoena that
he'd been given by the FBI in December
2019 when they finally agreed to take
possession of the laptop
and we published
um on October 14 2020 and within hours
the story was throttled online it was
censored and suppressed by Facebook and
Twitter and no doubt Google
even now you if you try and do a Google
search of Hunter Biden and the New York
Post you won't find very much you find
all the fake story cover-up stories in
the Washington Post or the New York
Times or Mother Jones or Rolling Stone
so
what we had was Facebook and Twitter
just decided they each had a different
reason and Twitter's case that was that
we had apparently violated their hacked
material policy even though nothing
about our story or the laptop was hacked
for Facebook they said they were
suppressing the reach of the story
pending fact checking well you know two
and a half years later there's been no
fact check and the reason I know that is
because
you know I've talked to many of the
other recipients of the emails on the
laptop and that's the first and easiest
way of verifying material on the laptop
is just to contact people
who received the same emails that Hunter
Biden was on and and asked them is this
have you ever seen this email is this
your your email
and all of them say yes
um and you know we verified this laptop
in a number of ways but
um I always look at the laptop
especially when I was writing the book
and continue to report on it as just one
piece of the jigsaw puzzle it's actually
not enough on its own you need the
material that Tony bobolinski also
provided the FBI back before the 2020
election
Tony bobolinski was a former business
partner of Hunter Biden who was involved
in one of the big Chinese deals
and he is an unimpeachable Source he is
a naval veteran from a family three
generations of military veterans he has
a top secret security clearance from the
NSA he's a successful and honest
businessman
um so he came forward because Rob he's a
patriot I mean also he felt aggrieved
because I think he was ripped off
by the bidens like everyone is
eventually
but he he was just an honest broker and
he went to the FBI before the 2020
election voluntarily he had a five and a
half hour interview with them in the
Washington field office he handed over
the contents of his three phones and he
never heard from them again